le prochain sujet risque vraiment de
vous surprendre en tout cas moi quand
j'ai eu les chiffres ça m'a vraiment
étonné radio canada est ciblé six ont
mené une enquête auprès de 42 université
résultat la majorité la majorité des
étudiants triche
denis martin chabot reportage je
culpabilise 11 actuellement je faisais
on ne se surprendra pas que ceux qui
trichent ne veulent pas être identifiés
à la télévision cet étudiant a déjà payé
100 dollars pour que rédacteur écrive
une dissertation à sa place je suis allé
sur le site internet kijiji j'ai
simplement écrit et donc devoir et le
nom est arrivé j'ai contacté la personne
était pas mal de nos devoirs qu'elle
proposait c'était littéralement la
rédaction complète de travaux moyennant
une somme d'argent récemment c'est sur
kijiji on trouve en ligne des dizaines
de services de rédaction clandestins une
dissertation peut coûter entre 100 et
2000 dollars selon le niveau et la
qualité du devoir et la nôtre chercher
les services est adapté aux compétences
de l'étudiant s'il écoute moi
complètement pourri en orthographe
ben j'arrive pas il présentait un
travail qui aura pas de forte de dans
des services comme un emploi de
professeur points comme mis sur le style
de vie de certains étudiants pour
attirer la clientèle
je manquais de temps je vais un travail
je veux une vie sociale
je veux liste des études sept autres
étudiants montre les solutions à une
dizaine de devoir qu'il a pu récupérer
dans un site de stockage partagé en
ligne qu'on appelle un drop box serait
pas kabachi d'un examen puisque pour moi
c'est cette rétro chic non respections
avoir mes collègues mais pour les
devoirs j récurrent au de 50% du monde
de fond la seule étude sur la question
au canada date de 2006 et a été effectué
auprès de 15 les l'universitaire 53 %
avouent avoir triché dans le cadre de
leurs devoirs 18% lors d'examens on
trouve toujours moyen d'amener avec nous
des appareils portables des appareils
numériques pour pour se changer des
réponses pendant l'examen
pourtant les conséquences peuvent être
graves quelqu'un qui est pris
parfait anti plagiat un échec pour le
court si le corps que l'on échoue fait
notre moyenne baisse
ça peut et mené à l'expulsion du corps
yann c b6 et radio canada ont récolté
des données auprès de quarante deux
universités au canada
notre compilation démontre que moins
d'un pour cent des étudiants au pays se
font prendre à tricher soit une infime
partie de ceux qui avouent le faire dit
cet expert son équipe devrait mettre à
jour sous peu leur étude qui date de
2006 sur la malhonnêteté universitaire
on devrait alors avoir un portrait plus
actuel de la situation à laquelle sont
confrontés les universités ici denis
martin chabot radio canada montréal